what are your thoughts on someone
writing a novel before they write the
screenplay
I think Hollywood is obsessed with IP
intellectual property and I think that
it makes it a lot easier if you can have
a book and also have a screenplay that's
going to put you so far ahead of the
game
do you think someone who's a novelist
can actually write their own screenplay
um I don't think every novelist should
write their own screenplay my experience
when party girl first came out one of
the first people who wanted it was
Melanie Griffith the actress Melanie
Griffith and she contacted me and said
um I want to make this and she was then
married to Antonio Banderas and she said
will you come meet with us and I went to
their house and I met with them and it
was so magical and I sat there with them
and I remember somebody who worked in
the house came in and said uh it's Mr
katzenberg on the line and and so he
left and Melanie goes tell Jeffrey about
party girl and I'm like I'm sure he
doesn't care Melanie wanted me to write
the screenplay she said this is your
story
um let's have you write it and I sat
down and I had no idea what to do many
years passed and then the pandemic hit
my boyfriend happens to not just be a
screenwriter but a structural genius and
he said to me you absolutely could write
this screenplay you just need the
structure I actually had tried to write
scripts in the past and I did actually
even get paid to do one but I really
didn't know what I was doing once he
mapped out the structure for me I just
was able to write it I thought I was
just doing it for fun keep me busy
during a pandemic
um I ended up having some friends read
the screenplay
um my friend Jeff garland from Curb Your
Enthusiasm and then my friend Rebecca De
Mornay who's an actress we did a zoom
reading and I heard that I mean again it
was just kind of for fun and I heard
them and this was good and everybody was
laughing and both of them said to me
afterwards this script works and that's
actually the one that's getting made so
it it took me 15 years to to end the
right structure to realize how to do it
they're definitely different skill sets
but there are definitely people who are
are able to write the book and the
script
and what is your definition of IP
that's a great question I I mean I think
IP is a book a podcast a YouTube show an
article anything that is the property of
somebody else that somebody could option
and then make into a movie or a TV show
why is it important for a writer to own
their own IP
it's important for a writer to own their
own IP because
don't have a lot of power the one thing
you've got is your idea and they can
rewrite you and they can you know they
can take your power away but if you've
got your idea and it's documented
clearly that that's your idea no one can
ever take that away from you
why didn't you originally want to write
the screenplay for party girl I didn't
want to write this screenplay because I
didn't think I knew how and I always
felt like I was hearing stories about
that that Diva person who ruined the
project because she was so like
committed to being the one who wrote the
script or whatever I'm a very practical
person which is why when the original
sort of bidding war over the book came
out I said who's paying me the most
which is the most option because I know
the chances of it actually getting made
aren't that great so who's going to pay
me the most and um and somebody said
well this is we want this to be a
lifetime movie and someone else said I
want this to be a Warner Brothers movie
I'm like well lifetime is shooting lower
that seems more realistic let's go with
that so I just I just want I wanted it
to be made and if I was gonna stand in
the way of it being made because I
insisted on writing the script that
didn't make a lot of sense once I
realized I could actually do a good job
at it that's when I was willing to do it
I was writing a screenplay different
than writing a novel
I think
writing a screenplay if you have the
structure
it can really write itself once you've
got the structure down when you're
writing a novel
um it obviously there are many more
words on the page but there are many
more nuances descriptions character
development
um I think it is possibly
I think more people believe they can
write screenplays and try than people
think they can write novels and try I
think if you're gonna try to write a
novel you're probably going to succeed
and it's going to be pretty good
there are a lot of really terrible
scripts out there
is it because maybe
um there's so much you know thinking and
different things that you're writing
into the novel where you can't really
portray that within the you know sort of
the screenplay format you've got a more
it's difficult
yeah I think I mean I I think this is
like if we're talking about the same
thing I think with movies
um I think people aspiring authors are
probably going to be readers
who read a lot of books as opposed to
aspiring
screenwriters who are probably people
who like movies who maybe don't have any
history or experience with writing so
it's very easy to kind of be like oh
Star Wars that's a great here's my you
know Space movie idea whereas that
wouldn't last very long if you were
trying to do that as a book you'd kind
of it would fall apart pretty quickly I
think
what if a novelist doesn't have a skill
set to adapt their screenplay
if a novelist does not have their skill
set to adopt the screenplay stay the
hell out as out of respect for your own
work hope that the best writer is the
one who adapts it that being said you
know I know of stories where a writer is
such a big writer that they are given
that opportunity and you know get
somebody who really knows what they're
doing to supervise I mean you're after
the best version of your book not you
know getting in the writer's Guild or
having the glory of your name as a
screenwriter how does a writer know
their novel actually should be written
as a movie
I will say
I'll talk from my experience I've
written
um seven books and there's only one that
people always say should be a movie and
I guess the difference is that there's a
Twist and there's
um there's something about it that's
cinematic I honestly do not know I
didn't write that one saying oh my God
this is going to be a movie and these
aren't going to be movies I think um I
think it has to it you know I don't know
science fiction genre in all these
genres what I know are sort of the
movies that would be the books that
would be made into romantic comedies and
they have to have they have to have
vibrant characters they have to have
surprising twists they have to have do
you see this couple in the beginning and
you want them to be together but they're
going to be realistic obstacles that are
going to keep them apart